the canal Adela Giudecca has been closed
by the police
that's because of franca and other
protesters it's a game of cat and mouse
they're protesting the large cruise
ships that pass through the lagoon
several times a week the activists want
to stop them from using this route
through the city it's David versus
Goliath Giulio has organized the
protests he's been fighting cruise ship
tourism in Venice for years even
goody-goodies laws had a bigger box
ashore the city depends on tourism some
people would even sell their own mother
it's all about making money but only a
few of the top profit from cruise ships
small shops restaurants and cafes earn
very little on cruise ship tourism
liners carry about 5,000 day tourists
who mostly don't shop or eat out
the only thing Venetians get from this
kind of tourism is dirt and pollution
the biggest problem is the invisible
currents that the cruise liners generate
Venice has always attracted sightseers
hordes of tourists come to experience
peaceful canals and narrow alleyways
souvenir shops multiply while the number
of locals is dwindling 58,000 residents
and just as many tourists fill the city
every day Matteo is one of the last true
Venetians every day he and his wife
witness how the city is changing it's
already been opened this used to be a
supermarket and now it's a gambling den
operated by Chinese infrastructure for
daily life is vanishing this is one of
the two remaining furniture shops left
in Venice this is where Venetians can
actually go and purchase furniture
otherwise you have to look outside
Venice two shots left will be nasty
according to Matteo Venice is turning
into an amusement park Venice land two
years ago Matteo and other Venetians
picked up on this slogan and protested
dressed up as mickey mouse and other
cartoon images
but like most Venetians Matteo also
lives on tourism he operates two hotels
in the city how does that fit in with
his protest yeah
visa paradox Venice is a paradox
intricity sure we live from tourists but
and that's what's ironic they're
contributing to what's driving us out of
the city franca and her fellow
campaigners are back from the protest
many of them will be facing a charge but
they don't mind so many people
participated in two different forms of
protest in the morning and at night on
land and on water it shows that a lot of
people want things to change but while
the protesters are celebrating a few
hundred meters away another cruise liner
is passing through the canal with four
hours delay but still unhindered